[Applause]
[Music]
this thing is brutal isn't it
i only read
the titles
oh this is awful man i didn't even
screenshot the
the
finish but okay here it is it's enough
dude
you gonna read the title or you want me
to sure yeah i can read the title and
then you you keep reading go ahead my my
boyfriend treats my vagina like it's
another person against my wishes
when you read this
it reads like a hostage situation
okay
okay
okay
she says
we're we are both each other's firsts
have been together for five years and
live together since first becoming
sexually active he's always done this
quote talking to my [ __ ] thing
that can alternate between cute
sweet and annoying the more he's done it
the more annoying it gets sometimes
it'll be stuff like she's really liking
this
and sometimes it's really cringe-worthy
like
she's really hungry isn't she
i thought it was gonna be like he's
looking at it like i'm gonna eat you
i'm
here comes the airplane oh god
oh my god
sorry i'm sorry
okay so she doesn't talk he doesn't talk
to it it sounds like he talks about it
to her yeah
yeah like god whoa now look she's really
acting up today
she says b she spelled behavior i o u r
so now i'm just realizing it's their
english
his behavior has been escalating
since the beginning of quarantine oh now
it's a memoir yeah
this is just a scene from the crown the
boy who talked the boy who talked to my
[ __ ]
the boy who talked willing the boy who
talked wistfully to my [ __ ]
sometimes he'll put his hand in my pants
or touch me over my clothes while i'm
doing something he's like sorry she
wants to feel
[Laughter]
good and then if i tell him i'm busy
he's all pouty like
but she's liking it so much yeah you
might be busy [ __ ] she's not doing
anything she's down dude she's looking
she's not doing [ __ ] down there dude
she's into it dude trust me
she's down dude
and it's true but that's just my body
this is like okay now this is like
this is feeling assaultish i feel like
any time we're together now he's
touching me and i can't believe i'm
saying it but my body needs to have to
off time oh yeah this isn't really about
the talking thing
i didn't even get this far in it i just
i went through the first two paragraphs
like we should read this and now this is
yeah that's
i don't know if this is related but he
he's tried to play footsie while we were
eating dinner with my parents once what
that's the only other boundary crossing
behavior he's shown this is weird
because it's not like him being selfish
because the stuff he's doing
okay i don't really know what yeah it
got a little weird at the end for sure
but he clearly thinks that her [ __ ] is
a different person than her
which is pretty weird could be psychotic
episode you know
[Laughter]
i just want to take this the funny way
and just talking to your lady like
like
so uh
what's up with your friend yeah yeah
what's up with her
could you say what's could you say
what's good to your friend for me excuse
me
just tell her that
just tell her that i like her
tell cat i said what's up
cat oh no
tell cat i said what's good oh god
what dude just just tell her hey
tell her i'm down if she is i'm kidding
i'm kidding but seriously tell her
seriously tell her i love
nah i'm really [ __ ] with her new
haircut
[Laughter]
yo tell her i said the ball thing is
sick
your girl gets out of the shower yo is
that cat yo cat yeah yo yo cat love the
new dude
yo i think she's smiling at me
yes she is
yeah she's smiling at me
[Laughter]
dude putting on a dope ass fit to get
into to get in the shower with your girl
like
[ __ ] designer t-shirt just like
drinking a beer with shoes on
yo it's good
trying to vape in there
can i get you a drink
if you want anything just like dude this
is my place like just let me know
your girlfriend's like what are you
doing shut the [ __ ] up
shut up dude so i'm embarrassing you
sorry about her this is my girlfriend
she's she's too drunk
she always acts up in these situations
you know how she goes man cat dude what
are you what are you doing later
you hungry
i know this is dope
i know this hot dog
is so stupid bratwurst stand around the
corner you know what i'm saying
my boy makes a real good bratwurst you
know what i mean my boy dick
richard actually is his full name
trying to impress your girlfriend's
vagina like it's her own person but
disregarding your girlfriend as a person
is so fun
oh [ __ ]
yo cat i got a new whip
you wanna see any time just let me know
i'll pick you up
shit's fine
hang out with your girlfriend she's like
she has she has clothes on you're like
oh it's just us today
no no i was just i thought i thought cat
might show up it's cool no it's chill
it's chill it's chill
where's she at
you're eating [ __ ] chinese food
you're like
is cat [ __ ] with chinese food
she should come next time i think she
liked this place honestly oh cat would
love this movie
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
i just feel like this is right up her
alley
what do you mean i always talk about cat
dude what's the big deal i don't talk
about her that much what she's just
really cool
she just has a good vibe i feel like
she's just trying to whatever it's sick
god don't be weird
yeah oh she's hungry
knock that off brother
[Laughter]
yeah i think all all it probably would
take from her is a big like hey
stop doing that
don't refer to my [ __ ] as a separate
being
she's not she's not anything she's me
can you imagine he goes to the station
oh she looks she just grabs his hand
no more
you're [ __ ] weird she's hungry
yeah yeah i'm mocking him
she there's no she [ __ ] weirdo logan
roy style yeah i mean he's hungry
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] off
no that's how you me you flip it on him
first of all it's not a [ __ ] she's
hungry are you a sicko
yeah yeah are you a sicko
i thought she just personifies her
vagina as logan roy
first of all it's not she it's he and
he's not hungry for anything
[ __ ] off
you